i'm more with uh i don't know what you
think about this i mean
joe rogan doesn't read comments or
doesn't mean comments much
and the argument he made to me is that
he already has an like a a self-critical
person inside like and i i'm gonna have
to think about what you said in this
conversation but i have this
very harshly self-critical person inside
as well where i don't need more fuel i
don't need
there i know i do sometimes that's why i
check negativity
occasionally not too often i sometimes
need to like
put a little bit more like coals into
the fire but not too much
but i already have that self-critical
engine that keeps me in check
i just i wonder uh you know a lot of
people who
gain more and more fame lose that
that ability to be self-critical i guess
because they lose the audience that can
be critical towards them
you know i do follow joe's advice much
more than i ever have here like i i
don't look at comments very often and
i'm probably using
twitter you know
five percent as much as i used to i mean
i really just get in and out on twitter
um and spend very little time in my ad
mentions
um i but you know it does it in some
ways it feels like a loss because
occasionally i get i see something
super intelligent there like i mean i'll
check my twitter ad mentions and someone
will have said
oh have you read this article and it's
like man that was just
that was like the best article sent to
me in a month right so it's like to have
not have looked and to not have seen
that
that's um that's a loss so but it does
um at this point a little goes a long
way because i yeah
it's not um it's not that it
for me now i mean this this could sound
like a
fairly stalinistic immunity to criticism
it's not so much that these voices of
hate turn on my
inner hater you know more it's more that
i just i get a
what i fear is a false sense of
humanity like that like like i feel like
i'm too online
yeah and online is selecting for this
performative outrage and everybody
everyone's
you know signaling to an audience when
they trash you uh
and i get a dart i'm getting a
you know a a misanthropic
you know cut of of just what it's like
out there
and because when you meet people in real
life they're great you know they're all
rather often great you know and um it
takes a lot
to have anything like a twitter
encounter in real life with a living
person um
and that's i i think it's much better to
to have that as one's default sense of
what it's like to be with people
than what one gets on on social media
or in on youtube comment threats
you